so you would be okay with the supreme  court leaving the question of  interracial marriage to the states  yes i think that that's something that  uh if you're not wanting the supreme  court to weigh in  on issues like that  you're not going to be able to have your  cake and eat it too i think that's  hypocritical  about griswold versus connecticut well  you can list a whole host of issues so  he very clearly heard the question  and the point here is  many republicans like mike braun like to  say  the supreme court really shouldn't  decide about all sorts of things the  supreme court shouldn't decide that  abortion generally speaking should be  legal it should just be up to the states  the supreme court shouldn't decide that  states aren't allowed to ban same-sex  marriage and so it's a reasonable  question which is the would you also  apply to this to interracial marriage  should states be allowed to ban  interracial marriage he clearly heard  the question and answered it